say you live your whole life and your
entire life you're not allowed a job
you're not allowed a bank account you're
not given those rights let's say you get
the right to Rome woohoo we've got the
right to vote right and yet you're okay
we're not being drafted right but the
rest of your life you're being deprived
of all of these roads you're going to
use one argument of the the draft to say
that the reason is because there has to
be around the right to the draft right I
understand okay let's put women into the
draft right sure do you want that sure
equally drafted Frontline where we've
you're talking like so so I'm saying
things
so you keep you keep you keep cutting me
off and it's quite rude cutting you off
because your your statements are so I
know statements are so made for the
camera those demons are so made for the
camera to be I'm saying just because
they're gonna get votes oh cool